welcome to Tucker Carlson tonight we
want to bring you the latest on what was
really a remarkable story that broke
late Friday in the New York Times we
didn't have time to address it then
according to what are apparently
high-level sources within the Department
of Justice in 2017 the FBI secretly
began an investigation into whether the
president is in fact a Russian agent the
FBI apparently believed that President
Trump could be a one man sleeper cell
personally taking direct orders from his
handlers in Moscow and working from
within the Oval Office to subvert this
country the FBI said they believe that
could have happened
so they spied apparently on the
president United States well shocking
doesn't even begin to describe this
story nothing like this has ever
happened in this country these
allegations are literally without
precedent that is not overstatement and
by the way the allegations are not true
the FBI did not find that Donald Trump
is a Russian agent no charges were ever
filed against him none will be but an
equally important question remains
unanswered how did this happen deciding
that a sitting president should be
investigated for treason is not a small
thing
officials within the FBI had to push for
this investigation and then marshal
evidence to justify it leaders at the
very highest levels of the agency had to
sign off on the whole thing all of that
happened but on what grounds exactly
that's what we would need to know in
order to understand this well thanks to
the time story we have some sense of the
answer and if you're imagining a secret
transmitter covered in Cyrillic scripts
discovered hidden in the Lincoln Bedroom
no think again there were no
cloak-and-dagger clues in this case
apparently the FBI assumed that Donald
Trump might be a Russian agent not
because of anything he did in secret but
because of things he said in public very
public standing on a stage on camera
while running for president here's one
of them there's nothing I can think of
that I'd rather do then have Russia
friendly as opposed to the way they are
right now wouldn't it be nice if we
actually got along as an example with
Russia
I'm all for it that was then candidate
Trump speaking at a press conference in
Florida at Doral in July of 2016
according to the FBI the words you just
heard are evidence that Trump may have
betrayed this country that's their view
but there's another way to look at those
words maybe Trump is right
nuclear Russia rather is a nuclear-armed
power on the other side of the planet it
does not have the power to invade the
United States it can't close
International shipping lanes it does not
seriously threaten our key allies like
Japan or Great Britain is there some
reason then that we should inherently be
in conflict with Russia is there more
over vast public support in this country
for fighting a proxy war in Syria with
the Kremlin and how many American
parents are anxious to send their kids
to die for the territorial integrity of
Ukraine an issue that we're supposed to
think is very important well outside a
few neighborhoods in Washington not very
many people it turns out so Trump did
raise a fair question at that press
conference in 2016 in Washington saying
that out loud is considered treason
Vladimir Putin policies almost being
parroted by Donald Trump you had at
Trump's say only nice things about Putin
he never spoke ill about Russia never
spoke ill about Russia that's the
evidence the United States senator holds
up to prove that the president may be
working for our enemies
so maybe Trump does like Russia who
knows by the way he's allowed to if he
wants to it doesn't make him evil it
just means he disagrees with prevailing
orthodoxy in DC and that's okay we're
supposed to have spirited debates over
questions like this but no longer policy
differences are now criminal offenses
today on CNN professional dumb person
max boot listed 18 reasons that the
president may be a Russian spy if you
look to the reasons a lot of them turned
out to be political positions that boot
just doesn't agree with firing Jim Comey
pulling out of Syria criticizing the
European Union and this is our favorite
one we're quoting supporting populists
s-- so the permanent war
caucus in Washington has succeeded in
criminalizing dissent from their agenda
that's what this is and by the way if it
were happening in a less developed
country we'd know exactly what to call
it
it's an attempted coup a political
leader gets elected on a platform that
law-enforcement agencies don't like so
those agencies try to put him in jail it
happens all the time in other places now
what's happening here former FBI lawyer
an anti-trump activists Lisa page
described the FBI's thinking in her
close to our testimony before Congress
Russia is the most dangerous country in
the world page reportedly said because
Russia works to quote weaken our ability
America's ability and the West's ability
to spread our democratic ideals end
quote so spreading our democratic ideals
as with the Iraq war is now the most
important thing that America does the
one thing we must defend at all costs
when did FBI lawyers start talking like
neocon propagandists no wonder max boot
is on board with this
our entire media and political classes
are with max boot and Lisa page too they
have lost their minds this past
September NBC News breathlessly reported
that Russia was using quote
sophisticated microwaves to cause brain
damage to US diplomats in Cuba no
surprise there really it sounds like
something those dastardly Russians would
do just because well now months later
scientists have determined the Kremlin
probably didn't have anything to do with
that the real culprit noise from
crickets and by the way not even Russian
crickets in these short-tailed crickets
non Slavic crickets whatever the media
didn't correct the story they ignored it
and they moved on they know who the bad
guys are evidence does not deter their
storyline Russian espionage is so so
widespread in fact that the act of
denying that you spied for Russia is now
confirmation that you did watch well
Kristy the president's tweet trying to
make the case that he's not a Russian
asset really just undercuts his own
defense
the president's tweet couldn't have been
scripted better if it was written by
Putin himself someone has to have told
the president
that undercutting the FBI insulting past
presidents and members of the US
government and criticizing their actions
to keep a state as safe is really
advancing Russia's mission our own
intelligence community has said that
those very things are exactly what
Russia is after so in the president's
response he's really just making
Russia's job easier you say you're not a
Russian agent therefore you're a Russian
agent who puts these people on TV that's
a question we should think about over
the weekend speaking of television CNN
president Jeff Zucker declared that
anyone who isn't spreading fear of
Russia is doing the bidding of Russia
the sucker didn't say that himself of
course he really speaks in public
instead he said his marionette
out as he often does to deliver the
message I was watching The Morning
America this weekend
and both mornings they led with
snowstorms and scares at malls and other
stories and not this and I just keep
wondering if if the public is ill-served
if we don't make it really clear what
the stakes of this story are how how can
a mortgage for not lead with this drama
I guess is what I'm saying I think I
think plenty of times we lead with it
with this drama so the eunuch heads to
the steps of the palace and reads the
proclamation message received thank you
very much but take three steps back is
the media's problem really that it
doesn't talk about Russia enough doesn't
seem like that's the problem whether the
president was working for Russia whether
Donald Trump was secretly working on
behalf of Russia whether Trump was
secretly working on behalf of Russia
whether President Trump was secretly
working on behalf of Russia whether the
president was secretly working with
Russia against America whether Trump was
secretly working on behalf of the
Russians whether Trump was secretly
working on behalf of Russia so whatever
visiting Trump was working on behalf of
Russia whether President Trump was
working on Russia's behalf whether the
sitting president was secretly working
for Russia whether President Trump was
working for Russia from The Oval Office
does every show on cable news have the
same writer well yeah it's the DNC
you've heard the script so many times
that it's like background noise music in
an elevator we never pause to ask the
obvious question which is does it make
sense does what they're saying logically
add up the Trump is doing the bidding of
Russia I don't know what sucess it just
for a second if you are Russia let's say
you're Vladimir Putin how would you try
to undermine American interests we'd
probably try to get America stuck in
costly expensive Foreign Wars you look
at Iraq and Afghanistan you would say
those wars have made America much weaker
want to try and replicate that
experience and say Syria in Libya
you might encourage America to do that
you might also encourage the u.s. to
adopt a self-destructive energy policy
you'd have the American government
sharply restrict the exploration of oil
and natural gas in the name of the
environment so that America produces
less energy why would you do that
because global energy prices would rise
and the US would have to import more who
would that benefit Russia a Petro state
their economy is dependent on energy but
Trump and this is weird behavior for a
secret Russian agent has done just the
opposite of that the United States for
the first time in my lifetime is an
energy exporter in fact it's the largest
producer of oil and gas in the world is
that good for Russia no it's not who's
pushing the opposite Oh weirdly it's the
left they're the ones pushing a green
new deal that would have this country
shutting down oil and gas wells across
the nation huh some never going to look
back in shame and confusion and wonder
how so many supposedly smart people went
completely off the deep end that's the
task for future historians for now it is
time for some radical transparency last
fall the president ordered the
declassification and release of Carter
pages FISA application how did an
American citizen who clearly didn't act
as an agent for Russia have his phones
tapped in his email
read by the federal government on what
basis we have a right to know that we
still don't so the president ordered it
he also ordered the unredacted release
of all text messages related to the
Russian investigation sent by Jim Comey
Andrew McCabe Peter struck Lisa Paige
and Bruce or the FBI officials well
instead of releasing them the Department
of Justice did four reasons that were
never really clear the president got
distracted and we've never seen those
documents it's obvious at this point
that the reason for not releasing them
isn't protecting American national
security
they just leaked the information about
the FBI investigation to the New York
Times on Friday clearly they have no
problem leaking information when it
helps them they haven't been released
because those documents might embarrass
the FBI this endless shadow
investigation has caused vastly more
harm to this country than any Russian
Facebook ad the president should order
the declassification of all documents
related to this it's clearly an abuse of
federal power if you want to restore
confidence in the federal government
bring in some sunlight tell the DOJ to
do that and if DOJ personnel refused to
do that fire them and replace them with
people who understand that they serve
elected leaders which is to say the
electorate which is to say voters the
people and not the other way around the
President appears afraid to do this he
seems to be intimidated by his own
lawyers but why what can official
Washington do to him now call him a
Russian agent plan to impeach him too
late they already have